hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the Julius bear
Challengers Championship where 2020 2021
Champion pragnananda is facing the 2022
champion pranava and uh Prague is
already leading the match like we said
we have to wrap it into Blitz matches
it's a series of four mini matches and
Prague already one uh one game with the
black piece is the one that we've shown
then one game ended in a draw and this
is now the third game so let's see how
this one goes I know pranav again with
the white pieces opens with E4 we have
E5 Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and now
Bishop to B5 final goes for the Roy
Lopez we have a six Morpheus defense
Bishop to A4 and the bishop the C5 the
Deferred classical defense with C3
Knight G2 E7 uh Shifting the Knight over
to G6 with castles and Knight the G6 now
uh D4 and also the E5 Pawn is nicely
defended now even though the white king
castles uh castled uh we have D4 the
chapter is 7 and now Bishop to G5 all
been played before nothing new here
quanta F6 usually you don't want to play
Pawn to F6 but in some lines of some
openings it is uh even recommended to do
so like in some lines for example of the
uh or of the petrol of Defense uh is
just very strong so Bishop back to E3
castles and The Rook the E1 and here
there are some games where D6 was played
but here we have King the h8 and it is
now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so let's see
how pranav continues this Knight beta D2
the Knight is doing the usual maneuver
not is coming to F1 then to G3 or maybe
E3 and then you will control a lot of
very nice squares here so the six by
Prague H3 taking away the G4 Square from
prox pieces and Bishop to D7 we have
Knight to F1 continuing the knights
Journey e captures on D for C captures
and pawn to D5 now and a black can be
very happy but also white is very happy
here Knight to G3 the captures an E4
Knight captures and now Knight C to E7
so you can start advancing that uh C
Pawn we have knighted the C3 also the
bishop on A4 is hanging so Knight to C3
Bishop captures and now Queen captures
you could also capture with the Knight
but it's not like the Knight is coming
to C5 or anything so just Queen captures
on A4 the Knight is better placed here
nicely centralized and now Knight to F5
and look at this beautiful Knight proc
has an F5 controls um a lot of squares
hearing the opponent's half of the board
and and also of course a lot of squares
on your on your side of the board it's
always best if your knight can control
eight squares not six or four so Rook
eight to D1 and now Rook to E8 uh again
it's a very strong Knight you do not
want to trade it for the bishop um uh
this bishop for the moment is a pawn so
no no reason to do that Rook to E8 and
queen to B3 now pranav goes after the B7
Pawn product defends it and not Knights
the D5 now the Knight here isn't really
threatening all that much it's just uh
very nasty to have the a knight in your
half of the board like this Knight is is
incredibly strong this Knight could be
even stronger but it's easier to
dislodge this Knight like you play C6
and this Knight is gone and you don't
really want to play G4 because that pawn
is in front of your king So Queen to D6
prop can always play C6 there's no rush
to do it right away
uh he developed the queen connects the
Rooks with Bishop to D2 and now Rook
captures on E1 uh Bishop captures better
than uh capturing with the Rook as you
do want your D4 Pawn defended so Bishop
captures an E1 and now Queen to D7 uh
it's a move I don't really understand uh
Prague wants to play C6 and for some
reason he plays Queen to D7 first I have
no idea why he played that if you guys
have any ideas why Queen to D7 uh you
are more than uh welcome to share in the
comments it would be very insightful to
learn what's this queen D7 idea business
uh business idea so Queen to C4 and now
C6 chasing away the Knight Knight the C3
and pawn to B5 now attacking the queen
and getting away getting rid of one of
the Defenders of the D4 Pawn so Queen
back to B3 and now Knight captures on D4
looks dangerous because you are putting
um a lot of pressure on that D file now
your uh the the Rook is x-raying the
black queen on D7 but Prague has
everything under control Knight captures
Bishop captures with knights the E to
now putting pressure on the bishop and
just Pawn to C5 but okay you can still
pile up on that Bishop Bishop to C3 you
cannot move the bishop it'd be great if
you could play Bishop captures enough to
check and capture The Rook but the queen
here is defending the Rook on D1 so Rook
to E8 uh this is how Prague decided to
go about this uh Knight cap percent d4c
captures and The Rook captures on D4 and
now his idea is Rook the E1 with check
and you can capture The Rook you don't
have to capture The Rook like you could
you could play King to H2 and then after
Queen C7 check G3 your Rook is still
hanging you're gonna move it back and
you get this position and okay you've
opened up the white king a little bit
but nothing spectacular
uh but instead just Bishop captures on
E1 uh pranav doesn't want to mess up his
Pawn structure any further and now Queen
captures on D4 we have Queen to E6 now
pranav offers a pawn for some
checkmating ideas if Queen captures some
V2 then this will just be a forced
mating two so instead H6 uh creating
some reading room for the king and H7
and now Bishop to C3 and this is now a
monster Bishop for pranav uh if um uh
Prague can't get rid of it from there so
Queen to D3 and now Pawn to G3 taking
away the F4 and H for uh F4 and H4
squares from the Knight Knight the E5
now and here Queen captures an A6
grabbing one Pawn but now comes Knight
to F3 with check of course you cannot go
to H1 Queen to F1 will be Checkmate so
King G2 and now Queen to D5 here Prague
is threatening some very nasty
discoveries and you should definitely
move the king out of the way which uh
pranav does first he gives one check
Queen C8 checking H7 and now King to F1
and uh Prague doesn't have anything
better he's down upon he should repeat
moves Queen D1 Chuck King to G2 and now
Queen to D5 and here pranav should
continue repeating uh otherwise he might
run into a very nasty Discovery but he
decided to continue the game even though
he was incredibly low on on time he
played Pawn to H4 and now there is a
problem the position is completely
winning for Prague but only if you find
the exact sequence of moves that wins
the game for him so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for Prague
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that you
can win the bishop and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Knight captures on H4 that with check
that's the good stuff and now the
problem is uh there are no moves if you
go King G1 this is Checkmate if you go
uh what else can you do you can play
King H3 maybe go up the board and not
much better Queen to H1 check King G4
now Queen to F3 check where you are
either uh asking for for the white king
to capture the Knight and then you're
gonna play F5 with an Unstoppable
Checkmate as the pawns are now covering
the G4 and the G5 squares and even if
you don't capture that you could go back
but still just F5 again everything is
taken care of here uh Queen to H1 will
be Checkmate regardless of um the white
king capturing then I don't know if you
go back of course Queen to G2 is
Checkmate as the Knight covers that
square so that's the problem that
piranha missed when he invited proc to
go for that pawn grab he was up upon he
was already down by a point in the match
and that's why I think he decided to do
that so uh yeah after after King to F1
uh he had to play this now comes Queen
to D1 check again the movie had to see
uh the G2 square is covered by the
Knight so you have to play Bishop to E1
and now you just win the bishop Queen to
D3 check King to G1 and now Knight to F3
check and he was in this position on
move 44 that pranav resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so Prague wins game one game three he
wins both of his games with the black
pieces and he wins the first rapid match
and this is what I meant by the title
that even though uh pranav made this
move when he was incredibly low on time
no one ever really loses the game on
time and it's something you hear very
often especially if you play in in bars
or libraries or you know wherever you
play someone will say okay yeah I mean I
lost on time but I I my position was
fine or even I was better but it's it's
always the exact thing thing you were
lower on time because your opponent
played better and you were struggling
more and you had to spend more time to
to get out of it I mean if if you give a
Magnus Carlson and anyone from from the
top 10 a lot of time they will find
great moves but if you give them very
very little time chances are Magnus will
emerge Victorious much much faster and
much more often
so yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by Prague
beating this year's Euless bear
Challengers Champion but there's there
are more mini matches so we'll see what
happens if Prana can bounce back and and
take a few wins from Prague so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
a big congratulations to those of you
who founded the winning idea it was not
an easy one to spot I would like to
thank Lucia basic Croatia Nikola
pokrosky during the Hagler and PG
mastering for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day